hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to yandere simulator I
don't know what's new in the game but
there's a lot of stuff so that's cool
and we're gonna find it
now there apparently there's demon
summoning and horrible new ways to
murder your friends or friends and then
get to your senpai cuz nothing is ever
gonna stop me from getting my senpai
like butterflies in my soul start a new
game damn it I know and sorry for the
door was it gender of your ideal lover
haha mailer than the male acid honest
this isn't to the bone hey the man
you've got a penis
I forget what oh yes oh yes red with red
or green yeah red and green and glasses
oh yeah that's my senpai are you sure
you want to proceed
not really but here we go in the murder
and death okay me oh he's so sweeping
and he's so we abou okay so we're gonna
start the week and then we're gonna be
exploring as this is new Wow swanky new
dogs dicks dogs whatever the term the
kids are using these days
alright the way they go change my
panties because this is a normal thing
that everyone does for relations with my
boy oh oh yeah skimpy alright equipped
got it
I'm wearing too skimpy because I'm gonna
be gossiping a lot
oh I haven't gone in town in a while
I'll go dance and prance around with my
bike the magical bike that can go Zuma
good oh god no oh lordy oh boy is there
a reason this lighthouse is just
floating on nothingness what'll happen
if I go into the ocean [ __ ] okay yes sir
is a weird ocean that just spills off
into forever oh my spine and my pelvis
everything in fact is broked Moomin
Ryder
away moving up the sporm
what is that I want you whatever you is
I want you in me on me around me I want
you oh you're a fountain but why do you
not know less my love is still good oh
[ __ ] oh okay never mind then
oh my spine I'm gonna thread the needle
[ __ ] that's dummy holy [ __ ] I don't know
I love my senpai oh [ __ ] now goddamn it
oh [ __ ] here we go again let's roll oh
[ __ ] just get to the goddamn school
there we go
please thank you god dammit I'm probably
late for school and everyone is going to
be mad with me oh wow oh wow they
changed it hot tits is awesome they took
out the long intro fountain I don't know
if that's good or bad but they still got
the weapons over here so that's
obviously convenient okay
I think the music's changed a little bit
a lots changed I have no idea what's
going on here it's cool though
nice who the [ __ ] are you what are you a
zombie join your club there's clubs now
awesome do I get a club that I can beat
people over the head with because that's
obviously convenient to what I'm trying
to do I'm gonna you are literally a
robot and that is bizarre but somehow
oddly arousing okay let's go in the
gardening club I guess that's so weird
how many other clubs are there Oh
awesome
a circular saw yeah it'll be awfully
useful and I'm getting my then by
there's a track that's me who the [ __ ]
are you another Robo aren't you Sports
Club oh I don't know what Club I would
want to join right away but I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna be a bit more
meticulous about my choices because they
don't know where they're I belong well
what are you oh are you the trunk that I
got to keep people in were they taking
bags
it's good nap I'm sorry I had to burp
creep up on me oh hello cooking club Oh
that sounds amazing but not yet not yet
I'm not ready for it yet there's a lot
of commitments and what is you the drama
club allowing you to hide your identity
and keep your DNA off the murder weapons
seems oddly specifically appropriate for
what I'm trying to be doing which is
falling in love with my senpai oh yes oh
oh yes oh yes play literally play I want
to join this club
hello I'm visibly armed let me just
shove that back into the skull where it
belongs maybe I need to do my ritual
hello are you part of the occult Club -
yes you better believe I'm ready to be
sacrificed for then why are there so
many people in here I thought it was
going to get a little more privacy in
this yeah are you all gonna summon a
demon I'm ready to roll any time you
guys are let's do this [ __ ] I'm going
to get this ritual knife
oh my cross just burnt alive but it's
alright let's do this I'm ready okay
alright then
I'm sorry what sounds a little scary for
you yeah go back to reading I'm gonna
close these doors here don't mind me I
just got a ritual knife you all know why
we're here
you know why you know what's up yeah
don't mind me I'm just gonna creep over
with you other than ritual knife hello
you ready to die let me take a picture
of whatever you're eating before you
kill you oh that's nice
that's lovely okay ha ha ha
nice nice nice alright now let's get the
bodies let's put them in the circle
let's drag their bloody corpses off the
way haha oops sorry I missed you I don't
want you to miss out hahahaha and a drag
and a what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
he's possessed by demons Oh God
the little too early for that I'm not
ready for yet now can you just cooperate
stop flailing alright now that we got
these demons here these really wrigley
violently dragging demons did drop you
okay now I'll put this back in the thing
put this back in this thing
Oh what did I do it oh no oh no oh god
no what's the [ __ ] you Oh Oh
commune no I don't wanna commune what's
this what the Freak is wrong with you Oh
let me take a picture of you buddy how
did I oh my god let's send that off even
info Chan doesn't know what the [ __ ] I'm
looking at well I'll just take a nice
little selfie with you that's a good
picture I'm really happy about this one
okay um I have no idea what these do but
this guy I'm drawn to this guy I don't
know why I'm not drunk I'm not innocent
I murdered five people just to get into
this plane of insanity okay found guilty
Oh glad that happened move that's cool
that's so interesting justice okay about
my sentence must feel what I felt okay
I have a lot of questions okay I feel I
feel like you're putting a lot on my
shoulders when your shoulders obviously
can't carry anything hello how you doing
lady you look nice and by nice I mean no
I'm adorable covered in blood
so long as it gets me closer to senpai
because that's literally the only things
I care about right now if we can get me
to senpai sue sue me for the [ __ ] you
I'm not patient I just murdered five
people as soon as I got to school today
what do you think I'm gonna do to you
I'm not I just want to play with senpai
in my okay all right then
have fun being weird and creepy hello
you
not really I murdered people whatever
yeah sure give it to me [ __ ] you too I'm
worthy of everything I'll kill everybody
in this school and then you next I don't
know what these mean there's a lot of
demands going on here I'm not a hundred
percent sure all right whatever you know
what [ __ ] all y'all [ __ ] you no arms
[ __ ] you sexy tits and [ __ ] you fire
face [ __ ] all y'all I'm going off to the
other world Oh kill people for fun and I
need to laugh my insanity away on this
pile of bodies gotta be over here
gotta be over here gotta be with the
candle right over my Gooch ha ha ha ha
how'd you get back over there whatever I
came to do and I'm totally sane now oh
the hell is this what the [ __ ] that's
weird ok
knowing the mouse might one oh no it's
an undertale reference run run
markiplier the comments are filling up
with people demanding that you play the
game sure is a good thing I'm tracking
all these bloody footprints Wow no one
will ever know ho there's everyone are
they gonna know probably well I better
not face my problems head-on best to
avoid them as best I can
sewing room there's no one in here Oh
Mac room there's no one in here this is
a bunch of [ __ ] oh hello can i learn
to fight even though I'm covered in
obvious blood Oh seems like a precarious
predicament everyone ignore the fact
that I went in here no one suspects a
thing I'm gonna just stuff myself in
here where it
oh man oh that's funny
who's on the computer screen hello it's
me who's me I can't see I don't know who
the [ __ ] are you talk to you about what
I got a bassoon on my back no not at all
oh cool I'm very popular undertale
reference I have no idea come back don't
leave me with the comment I got a giant
[ __ ] I've got a giant stand-up bass
case on my back back is this can I
attend class please teacher
oh hi teacher like what no I take my
music very seriously I just look so
simply when on my back okay what I'm
gonna do is uh snap still not
implemented still not anybody still not
okay I'm gonna do is I'm gonna look up
how to get that occult thing cuz that is
hunky-dory coolly boolean okay I'm back
I discovered what I need to do I was
actually remarkably close to what I
needed to do because you need to murder
someone with a knife to get into the
Shadow Realm you only need to murder one
and then put it back but then after you
talk to the guy with the face you know
the fun face you put the knife you you
come out of the Shadow Realm and then
you murder and dismember
five bodies because that's the thing you
can do now I should have known by the
book that that little lady was reading
it was very nice except it wasn't so
anyway what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
take the knife and then I'm gonna murder
someone who isn't a part of this club
because there's a possibility that I
need them later because I need to
dismember five total of five bodies yes
oh I hit on every subject that I needed
before I even knew I needed it
I need the circular saw which is part of
the gardening club and I don't even need
the job [ __ ] you what God losers are
you who are you what the hell all right
you know what thank you
who do you think you are [ __ ] I'll
smack down with you guys with your
stupid wooden sticks I got a ritual
knife I can summon demons with my own
mind I can kill you as a okay anyway
I'll be back for you I'll deal with them
in another episode okay what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna take these [ __ ] out
and then I've got the perfect target of
the people outside of her [ __ ] when you
do that when you spawn it it looks
horrified so I know what I'm gonna do
now is I'm going to go find my little
circular saw forever I put that all
right it better be over here good yes so
now that we got that and we've properly
gone into the depths of insanity that we
needed to go to don't mind the bloody
footprints they mean nothing
haha okay
so now I'm gonna drag them all into the
middle and then properly dismember them
come on come on don't fight me come on
that-a-girl come on that's what I
thought okay so now that I got the
circular saw now I just need to
dismember them okay all right then
again look at that so nice all in a
day's work see if this works I don't
know if it's gonna work I may need to
get five more bodies all right
Wow this didn't seem to work so well I'm
gonna do Oh God
Oh God hey it's a puppet show
ha ha ha I'm gonna beat someone to death
with this arm yes scared me almost but I
did it yes okay so yeah this is what I
wanted to happen okay cool
yeah yeah yeah I had to drop oh oh oh go
beans or something I did it yeah so the
thing was yeah this is really weird and
creepy and I don't know why this is all
happening but it is and it's awesome
so what happened was you needed to drop
the arms in so I just pulled all the
body parts out and then dropped the arms
it oh oh oh I'm mobile oh my god oh this
is amazing oh this is so amazing oh I
can fly take this robot and nothing
happen to you but think that as a
warning
I guess oh geez okay alright time to go
hon some people I guess I'm not exactly
sure what I'm
hello anybody in here
hi what am i intruding on are you the
principal not for long oh never mind
then maybe I'll just be out of your hair
weird floating girl whoa whoa whoa whoa
well Wow well what the hell what
happened was someone in that classroom
okay whoa well this is a nice cinematic
view am I going off to my destiny is the
girl from the ring I'm gonna take a
picture so cool so cool oh god it's so
weird so weird so weird
oh [ __ ] alright so that's all the time
we got for yandere simulator thank you
everybody so much for watching
I have only scratched the surface on
what's new in this game there is so much
cool stuff so let me know in the
comments what I should do in the next
videos for this game because there's a
lot left to explore but don't give it
all away I want to find out for myself
check out other cool yandere simulator
videos and of the air simulator animated
video links in the description below
thanks again everybody for watching and
as always I will see you
in the next video